so my favorite scene in all the movies
I've ever seen in my whole life is from
one edge even Geena Davis's movies one
of the greatest movies of all time that
stars women it's about women and was
directed by a woman a league of their
own and the scene is when Gina decides
to quit baseball because she says it
just got too hard and her coach Tom
Hanks tells her of course it's hard if
it wasn't hard everyone would do it it's
the hard that makes it great
and that's why Gina's great since 2004
she's tackled the hard work of changing
the way the media portrays women the
Geena Davis Institute on gender in media
has done this using the most powerful
tool of all data because a lot of gender
bias is unconscious it's unintentional
people don't realize what they're doing
until they see the data and when they
see it they change it I come from a
family of women my parents had four
daughters I'm the third middle child
actor obvious and when I tell people
this they often say jokingly for girls
oh your poor dad as if girls are a
misfortune they say girls costs more
money which if you think about that for
a second what that means I mean when a
baby is birthed in a hospital the cost
the same to birth the hospital bill
isn't any different but the thing that
changes is what which gender Society
later decides to put a price on these
expectation biases begin with media this
idea is so pervasive pervasive that's
acceptable even normal even considered
harmless enough to joke about to say for
girls oh your poor dad but luckily for
me my dad because he's the best
no offense of the other dads in the room
but mine has
always said oh no it's wonderful having
girls is wonderful because he considers
it a privilege to have gotten to see
four very different girls grow up and
become themselves he feels a lucky he
got to witness this in his own house
because his generation didn't get to see
a lot of that in media and thanks to
Geena Davis that's changing she's not
trying to reinvent what it means to be
female she's simply trying to show real
lives and real possibility on screen her
Institute's motto is if she can see it
she can be it
Gina's work is changing what we're all
seeing in media which means this isn't
just great for girls it's great for guys
it means every guy can be as lucky as my
dad who feels privileged to experience
the stories of his daughters and which
means every girl can start to see her
myriad possibilities see it in the
foreground in the background in the
images of the world reflects back to her
if she can see it she can be it in a
league of their own
Gina's character quits because it does
get hard but then she comes back she
comes back and she says the Tom Hanks
don't you ever shave cuz you look like
[ __ ] and that's one Tom realizes we're
gonna win and then there's this boy on
the sidelines can you guys tell I love
this movie there's this boy on the
sidelines saying you're gonna lose and
Tom Hanks throws the glove at him and
Gina gets back in the game even though
it's hard and when she lets go of the
ball to let the other team win you
realized that the story wasn't about
winning for her it was about her little
sister kid that was the win
so Gina from all your sisters out there
from the generations of women here today
and yet to come from all the women
you've inspired and whose lives you
changed with your work thank you it is
an honor a privilege and a goddamn dream
to present you with this year's Jean
Hersholt Humanitarian
[Applause]